Tailandia recupera su potencial Y es que
esta nación de Asia un destino preferido
para disfrutar del asueto de año nuevo
empezó a recibir a ciudadanos chinos que
viajaron tras el levantamiento de la
política cero covid estamos emocionadas
de volver a Tailandia hemos estado
esperando durante tres años la política
cero covid surgió tras el brote de Kobe
19 en China con la intención de
erradicar por completo la enfermedad
pero ante el impacto que generó en la
economía y la vida cotidiana las
autoridades decidieron levantarla no
obstante el temor existente por los
contagios surgidos en China durante las
últimas semanas llevó a la OMS a
pronunciarse a fin de evitar lo que
definió como medidas discriminatorias
compartimos la opinión actual del centro
europeo para el control de enfermedades
que un aumento en curso en China no se
prevé que tenga un impacto significativo
en la situación epidemiológica del Kobe
19 en la región europea en este momento
Corea del Sur y Japón anunciaron la
imposición de medidas restrictivas
contra Los viajeros chinos y como
respuesta Beijing suspendió la emisión
de visas para ciudadanos de estos países
una situación que se presenta en medio
del optimismo de los vendedores
surcoreanos por la llegada de los
turistas chinos